scusate se mi intrometto manco fosse un
mio video ma una intro la facciamo
qualcosa è tardi dovrei andare a casa
noi è tardi che dovessero a casa questi
tutti gli horror dovrebbe essere ora
sono sulla bici posso girarmi e suonare
il campano spero che vi sia piaciuto se
devo consegnare un pacco questa roba non
solo su una bicicletta bellissimo è un
ep wheels and honey primis oro rosa
bulgara in flight to one la tournée la
tua nella sul cartiera sui piatti e la
tournée a non so cosa voglia dire io con
la userei la bicicletta così a questi
orari un po malsani però fai quello che
so proprio perché non si veda un palmo
dal naso non si vede niente c'è un faro
porca [ __ ] mi scusi è che non si vede
un cazzo qui e mi stavo andando
contromano che ne so io che corsia si va
nel senso giusto mica ce la patente ecco
è comunque nonostante il tuo anea porca
[ __ ] stavano spaventapasseri la madonna
ma che anzi è sto gioco
è orribile sta cosa sono spaventata io
comunque mi cago addosso perché
no no no no no io vi ammazzo io vi
ammazzo incredibile il bello è che mi
sono girato io non sia citato lui subito
girato io nel gioco se non mi fossi
girato non avrei visto questo quella
merda mi sono calato nello salvaguardi
eccezione le persone laggiù non andrei
io va bene non mi guardo più indietro
quindi 60 latini sono cagato nelle
mutande tra nell'est adesso mi guardo io
no vabbè sapendo che c'è gente dietro è
impossibile non guardare la mendes non
c'è più
scelsa c'e nel sangue rispetto a prima
va bene
salve
c'era un tizio dietro no no vi prego
ragazzi per favore ve lo chiedo per
favore no
la tizia è sparita se passa un treno non
è passato prima o poi prima o poi me lo
becco in faccia è però sicuro
allontanarsi dalla linea gialla che
succede sono ancora qua va bene il
leisure
bindi che però è tutta scritta strana
non mi guarderò mai più dietro
paradossalmente è stato lui più brutti
juncker che ho avuto negli ultimi almeno
almeno almeno sei mesi cioè secondo me è
veramente uno in più perché non è tanto
il jobs che visse ma perché mi sono
girato in quel momento è stato orribile
che non c'è più nessuno smetta rigirarmi
perché mi sto pagando in mano con una
parte questo io
andrei depressiva bene se qua quanto
sangue sempre più incasinata la faccenda
lui che è che non ho visto non l'ho
visto e nel meglio che non abbia visto
forse forse meglio per una volta mi sono
girato
bene
beh allora ho preso un infarto prima che
non avrei dovuto prendere adesso ne ho
scampato uno che invece avrei dovuto
prendere sempre guardandomi indietro tra
l'altro c'è il treno
ok io vostro qua
sorrenti treni sto paese cioè proprio
qui 23 i dharma forte proprio la siamo
qua
salve aspetta anche la in treno doveva
si può pulire che è un po sporca faccia
il cazzo che vuole
poi dato la alla luce data dal treno che
passa vabbè
giochi si chiama burger elfride pighi
non vedo cosa c'entrino gli hamburger in
questo gioco va bene salve oddio la
respinta il cazzo sono mike tyson a io
respingo i fantasmi sono fortissimo
caso incredibile prima volta che ho
spinto alcuni non or swim in giro no
ecco a posto prima che prima le spinta
non ancora non ancora attenzione ma mi
sa che mi sa che la dello stivale
schivarla dalla beach proprio quando si
avvicina la schifo va da un'altra parte
porca [ __ ]
è bruttissimo guardava come capitava
malissimo con la faccio qui
dovete mai fatto cosa fa non capisco
vado ad essa sister madonna lab è però
non posso scarsa che cazzo
percorso a ostacoli cos'è non so neanche
da dove arriva cioè posso andare a casa
vado a caso michele scrive dalla schivo
minchia troppo figo nel fosso
ma andata benissimo stavolta lega
ci abbia abbiamo un traguardo prima o
poi lo continua così novità però perché
è un po complicata la faccenda
no no no
non credo che quello sia un modo
corretto per andare in bici per ora le
fai fai tu e non sense non c'è non
c'entra e non c'entra e non c'entra e
non c'entra e non c'entra non c'entrano
perfetto importante che non mi investa
niente
che c'è stato prima non c'era stata una
galleria
anna già prima non c'era la galleria o
sbaglio noi ragazzi io non posso farlo
astarita fatemi arrivare da qualche
parte piuttosto anche a silent hill vedo
che c'è una torre laggiù c'è da qualche
parte porterà starò chiuse
ok ok c'è gente c'è gente fuori dal
ponte volevo giocare oa questo epico
eh no no no è morto come fa a guidare
come possibile
nuova maserati questa bella macchina
incazzata di mancato comunque pedana lo
zio
pedara lo zio pedala pedala che se lo
siamo nella merda ma che è comunque lo
zio dentro ti ho schivato tutto la
macchina ci passa sopra si cosi ne frega
niente un gippone tanto giappone
devo schivare i burroni mentre guardo
dietro 109 infattibile magari non guardo
dietro visto che non è proprio
necessario
ma che non gliene frega niente dovrebbe
rimanere impantanata nel non niente ne
frega niente io fossi in te mi prende
non lo so fermati a un autogrill fa
qualcosa che palle papà me like a car e
il cazzo soddisfacevano capito lo zio
oddio mica come ho fatto non lo so come
ho fatto a tenere se fermava è per forza
un ragazzo fassino questa strage ecco la
bicicletta bea di amazon ne ha non solo
il cazzo è stata per galleria non c'è la
prima la galleria curvata
chi
sta nei lavori in galleria va bene ma
quello che la macchina
non so chiedo
ne frega più un cazzo la macchina va
bene si sta passando godzilla
tale laratta stata tappata
ci sta un gigante di pietra
beta cioè il colpo ricerca questo o
fratelli attento al gigante beau mi
chiama tirato uno schiaffo può essere
che sta andando al massimo più orca
[ __ ] io più veloce di così non posso
andare ai ragazzi ma io non posso darvi
oggi di cosi cazzo mi colpisce
sto stronzo maledetto qualche gioco è
raga io non ho capito tanto pensavo
fosse molto più corto sto gioco invece
no
dura anche tu a dea abbia raggiunto to
one a tu quaderno cibo assi porca [ __ ]
che restano ai bracci delle agende in
demuro ok mi fanno dito meglio quando
passo avanti grazie
to one
to one al audire tunnel tournée al sole
to one a sono fuori la tournée a valla e
al divertimento
vecchiaccio stare la macchina quarta a
[ __ ] che male non devo prendere anche
il nomignolo farne anche toccare a siti
si molestano dal nullo parto lungo
sottolinea la sala macchine a salve è
vestito è davvero potuto far retromarcia
è un tunnel così sono morto morto ora è
finita ancora basta
il comico perché dice adesso se vale già
sentono
istruite troppo tardi
va bene
quindi sono morto
ero già morto prima vicino è sempre più
scomparsa toast o mondo ad un anno
quanto questo cristo gioco c'è veramente
tale qualcuno li chi è
giorno
cos'è sta roba il centrodestra porca
[ __ ]
ok
ma hanno inchiodato
ragazzo di chi sei salve a quella di
prima
ma puoi guardarmi anche da davanti e
senza parola per forza è il crociato il
corpo sia servita passato abbastanza
grazie
tu non appartieni
alcuno che io non appartengo a cosa che
sembra avere gli shinigami questo io
posso entrare dentro to one si sono
tuffate a nel porterà
quindi
no sono salvo ciò anche il mio hamburger
finito tra l'altro l'annoso magnato
no con le macchine
hai visto che la è visto che l'hamburger
quello sporco di rosso no cosa è
no way
novoli aspetta
no non ci credo io ero quello in
macchina sin dall'inizio avevo investito
stati sia con i sensi di colpa mi sono
fatto sto viaggio né e mi sono distratto
perché stavo mangiando un hamburger
no ragazzi pazzesco pazzesco pazzesco
che finale
buon appetito pelli badò ma ragazzi ma
che gioco ma che gioco pazzesco
complimenti no ragazzi pazzesco non
sarebbe aspettata da un gioco così come
lo sai perché poi è un player su
internet non mi sarei mai aspettato un
gioco del genere bellissimo spero che mi
sia piaciuto ragazzi questo genera mento
è un mi piace fatemi sapere cosa ne
pensate di commenti perché veramente
meritava tantissimo come jobs lato il
finale mamma mia complimenti e noi come
sempre ci vediamo al prossimo video
belle ragazze
[Musica]